Palestinians were banking on the support
of the Arab League States and they got
it the Ministerial Council confirmed the
Palestinian government's rejection to
the so-called deal of the century in its
current formula the council stressed
that the acceptance of such a deal would
mean waiving the historical rights of
the Palestinian people because it's
considerably less than the legitimate
ambitions of the Palestinian people
President Mahmoud Abbas detailed at
length the reasons why the US Mideast
plan should be rejected saying it adopts
the Israeli position in full leaving
little or no room for any negotiations
u.s. president Donald Trump has given
the Palestinians for years to engage
with the plan but her best said Israel
will use that time to push ahead with
policies which are contrary to
international law and further solidify
the occupation the moment they said
Jerusalem is annex Israel I knew I have
to say it loud and clear we will never
accept that under any circumstances I
will never sell Jerusalem the Arab
League has presented the Arab Peace
Initiative from 2002 as a solution for
the palestinian-israeli conflict it
calls for the end of the Israeli
occupation before Arab and Islamic
states normalize relations with Israel
theater Sarah Ali be the influence of
the regional conflict led some states to
go along with the US administration
their fear from Iran push them closer to
the main enemy which is Israel this has
reflected negatively on the Arab scene
on the official level the Palestinian
leadership hopes that diplomatic
pressure could help keep the Israeli
plans in check but Palestinians we spoke
to here today say that they've been
hearing similar statements from
different organizations for decades and
their lives under occupation have only
been getting worse don't know a good man
said if the Arabs are with us the US and
Israel won't do this to us remember
senator Larabee I'm not waiting for the
Arab states they already sold us off if
we are split amongst ourselves what are
we expecting from them Palestinian
officials say the Arab League's position
helps them rally support
especially as the Israeli Prime Minister
promised to push for annexation as early
as next week I do believe that the the
the rejection of this plan must must be
come from the international community
because it is illegal
it's undermines the international law
not only undermines the the rights of
the Palestinian people the Palestinian
leadership is also looking for the
backing of the African summit the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation and
the United Nations Security Council
officials here say it's not the u.s.
plan itself they fear
it's how Israel can use it Neda ibrahim
al Jazeera the occupied West Bank